but with a new year means new
resolutions and Findlay Subaru of Las
Vegas the sponsors of today's segment is
ready to set some exciting goals for
2023. take a look
[Music]
well it's a new year which means new
goals but the same love for Subaru of
Las Vegas we are here with our friend
Burton Hughes happy New Year happy New
Year so great to see you and as we head
into 2023 let's jump right into it we're
all talking about resolutions do you
yourself have some resolutions for the
brand and the community well you know we
love to do things in the community and
you know it's always my wish my prayer
that that we were able to do more and so
being able to reach out and just find
new ways to connect with our community
and and our customers and and share the
love you know that's what it's all about
yeah you guys are so involved in the
community always doing different events
and giving back and is that going to
carry over into the new year and kind of
align with your your love platform here
uh absolutely we just finished our
annual share of the love event it was
the 15th year that we did it and four
great National Charities are going to
benefit ASPCA make a wish Meals on
Wheels and the national park Foundation
two great Hometown Charities Red Rock
search and rescue and the just one
project we can't wait to give those
checks out in the spring they're going
to be a large checks I tell you what but
you know we're going to continue that
and on a monthly basis we do great stuff
a new one that we just started is with
the Lost Las Vegas desert dogs the brand
new lacrosse team here in town and we're
doing teacher of the week so we're going
into the schools and we're celebrating
Educators that are doing something great
with their kids and and recognizing
their service giving them some funds to
to minister to their classroom and their
kids and and bring them to the the game
and celebrate them well I love that and
you guys just continue to work with new
partners new people teachers everything
is so important in the community so
thank you for all that you do and we
couldn't stop by here though without
talking about the cars let's get up
let's walk and talk because you were
just saying you have more cars on your
lot than in a long time and what makes a
Subaru perfect for say a family or
someone looking for a car in the new
year Well you need a car that's going to
do a lot of different things and of
course Subaru is well known for their
symmetrical all-wheel drive which means
you can take a Subaru places that other
cars can't go and you know in other
words if you want to go up to Red Rock
you want to go to uh Lee Canyon by the
way at Lee Canyon we actually have
Subaru specific parking because we have
a partnership with Lee Cannon as a
national company and so you know those
those are great places to go with your
all-wheel drive Subaru I had no idea
that is so exciting and even more of a
reason to get up there it kind of feels
like a quick escape from Vegas and you
can do it safely in a Subaru anything
else as we head into the new year that
you just want people to know well I I
have to really kind of restate what you
said earlier we finally have new cars
for for people to come and take home now
so even though you may want to order it
online and wait for it we actually have
vehicles uh in stock ready for immediate
delivery
well thank you to Findlay Subaru of Las
Vegas for sponsoring this segment you
can give them a call at your number on
the screen
702-495-2100 they have a special offer
giving 3.9 financing for well-qualified
buyers for up to 48 months on select
2022 and 2023 models